this is a production of cornell
university
okay so my presentation is how do you
know your pricing is right
uh and come on down um
this is part of a
a uh a program um
there we go uh that i i was funded uh
for through
uh the northeast region
risk management extension grants part of
usda and nifa uh this is a collaboration
with no for new york uh and uh food
justice certified so it's a broader
program uh this my my part is is uh is a
is a section on that uh we're really
looking at how to how to be more
accurate with pricing
uh and that starts with uh understanding
cost of production
um
the other part uh in this um
that i won't cover today but in the chat
box i was of a link to a survey uh we're
looking to help uh to get farmers to
help to fill out and and we can uh
through our team be able to put together
uh
some assistance uh
dealing with labor
um and and other um business type
um
issues that you might be having as part
of the agricultural justice project
um so it's a it's a little bit of a serv
long survey uh but you get results from
it uh and we'll
um and you'll be contacted if you if you
wish uh and we can we can help you with
uh with going through
uh a lot of what's going on and and
looking at labor
here
um
so
let's get started uh there are a lot of
steps as you know uh getting you know
getting going in in
um
vegetable production
um and so lots of things to keep track
of but every step along the way it seems
it's costing you money one way or the
other uh so i want to
i want to like lay the groundwork on
this uh so under for everyone to
understand where the costs are coming
from
keeping track of them uh so that when it
when you
you need a lot of information to
accurately create a price
uh that is going to both reflect uh
recovery of your costs of production
your
your own wages wages of your workers uh
and and and
eventually that it leads to
a profit
at the end of the day
that can be reinvested back into the
business but along the way is also going
to give you a lot of financial
information that is going to be really
critical for you to
making
decisions uh for your business
you know so it it's not enough anymore
to know just how to grow plants
it's not enough to know how to you know
use the latest equipment you've got to
be able to afford the latest equipment
you have to be able to afford the crazy
high prices for use equipment
it's not enough i think to sell just
farmers markets or csas unless you
really you've got your numbers down
so you need to be on top of your
financial
situation to make these strong business
decisions
so it's it's uh you know you've got to
you know so
that that entity of being a business
manager is coming out loud and clear in
this
and everybody goes i got so many truck
crops to keep track of especially if
you're diversified operation you may
have 60 70 different types of crops out
there
uh and we know this is
this is the situation
and um
but there are ways of of handling on
this you know uh and so uh you know we
i'll give you the groundwork and you can
move on from there
so
which what should i be getting you know
for
whatever crop you're growing over the
years this is one of the most common
questions i get you know just around
when harvest starts i mean you know i've
got i have five acres of beans uh how
much do i sell them for where do i sell
them these types of questions uh so that
my my reply to this is well what what
did it cost you to grow it um
because i there's no way i can give you
a number that will accurately reflect
your per your particular situation
growers often reply to me to that is
well i i paid i know i paid so much for
for seed
and i pay a lot for labor
um
but
other than that you know it's there
it's lost
you know
so figuring out cost of production is
really important you know like i said
really provides important information
so you know it it
you need to know you know to set prices
um
you want to run your business so you
need this this information there i mean
if you're filing taxes on that there's a
lot of that information you fill in on a
schedule f
um
you know you you're going to want to
purchase some equipment can you afford
to do that
um
what do you want you know if you want to
grow more
what do you need to expand the operation
you know uh the there's there's a lot to
it it seems like the bigger you want to
be the the the more exponential the the
costs are
can i afford to hire workers uh with
higher labor costs you really need to
know if you can afford this uh and and
that's that's a you know and first and
foremost you've got to be able to pay
yourself a living wage
before you can you can afford to hire
more workers or or pay them what they
need
oh then you're looking at the markets
you're going to is that market really
making you money um you really need to
analyze that i visit
over the years i've visited a lot of
farmers markets
watch how how some some operations set
up their pricing it just seems like they
just make it up as they go along um and
if they if they end up with a fistful of
dollars at the end of the day
they think they've really done well but
do they really know what it costs them
to to do that
um
you know
part of production
do you know which tasks is costing you
the most money yeah i bet everybody can
say oh weeding it's probably right up
there um but what else there may be
other things
so and then you need to figure out so
where and how can i become more
efficient if
if these
some of these activities are really
costing me a lot of money um
and then
you know
one of the most important ones can i
make a living
a living from this income
this question i am hearing over and over
again from growers
who are probably approaching the seven
year mark in business
they're looking at improving profits
comes from improving efficiency
you know and that's that's been an
answer from extension for a long time or
an industry oh you got to become more
efficient you got to become more
efficient but how do you know
that becoming more efficient is even
affordable you know what what does it
take to become more efficient
you have to have to be able to answer
these questions
one of the ways you know profits can be
improved
by raising prices
and and knowing your costs is critical
to figuring this out accurately and i
hope by the end of today uh that you
you'll start being seriously thinking
about how you know how your pricing uh
might might be changed in in order to in
order to improve uh and if if people
have questions at you know after this
presentation or you know if you think of
things down the road don't hesitate to
give me a call or an email
i'd be happy to work with you on this
some years back i conducted a survey
um it was sort of a broader topic but
part of the questioning
was asking
farmers about how they set their prices
and i set up uh
some some um
multiple choice questions uh you know oh
and and so some sort for this for this
particular question how do you set your
prices one of the options was
whatever the farmer next to me at the
farmer's market charges
or whatever the grocery store charges
that's what i base my information on
uh
i put this one in there to see if
anybody actually really guessed at their
prices um
and um and so i i've received back uh
about a hundred and fifteen hundred and
twenty or so responses
um to the survey
uh so it sort of broke out this way um
about 96 percent uh fell into these
three categories what scared me to death
was saying that 30 people said they
guessed um
but
that that's one um i hope they were just
kidding
but i had four percent said they
actually figured out their costs first
so i thought well there's hope
so this is uh this is an important point
um
another uh question i asked um
was about you know do you think you're
being profitable is your operation where
you want it to be are you making enough
money
that 96
said uh would like to think so uh but
they're not really sure uh and part of
the reason it came down to was uh record
keeping everybody hates that um but they
really did not have a handle on on you
know they had an idea but they didn't
really have an accurate handle on there
four percent said yes they did um that
they did know that they were being
profitable uh and those turned out to be
the same four percent uh who answered
that they did the uh they they knew
their costs
so a little lesson there i think um
but i can understand everybody think you
know how am i going to figure this stuff
out it's a real headache not an
accountant
and personally i took an accounting
course and i can understand people's
hesitancy about trying to get dive into
accountants and doing any sort of
account work it's boring it's it's hard
to to keep things straight but if you
can balance a checkbook
then you probably can do this uh
reasonably well
but it takes time uh and it really
starts off with uh being able to uh you
know
keep good records
and and um
you have to find all your records
maybe on the uh
on the dashboard of your truck or behind
the seat or or somewhere but uh you
should start getting into the habit of
really trying to keep
um keep good records so you can get back
you know and and and use them to your
advantage if you're an organic grower or
you're doing food safety
audits certifications you're probably
already keeping
records so you're you're halfway there
and record-keeping yeah it's a lot like
weedy uh if you don't keep up with it
you're gonna get buried and at some
point
that information that could have been
harvested is gonna be lost
and you missed an opportunity to
have some of that detail that you really
want
in there
so getting into this so what i want to
do is uh
is really start building the case for
um
of of of using using identifying your
costs
putting it together
uh and and
there's uh some you know in into a crop
budgets
uh and and then um and then analyzing
uh your costs versus your selling price
there
i've looked over the years trying to
find uh some easy to use programs or uh
or things that are really relevant to
the northeast um and and even you know
to
even to new york but a lot of it is out
of date there's just two sources that i
have worked with that that that's really
uh that has done a really decent job
with it
one is uh and i'll get to this in a few
minutes uh but um university
massachusetts uh a few years back uh put
together some cost of production
sheets um
and and then uh also that was around the
year about uh
20 years ago i guess um and then about
10 or 12 years ago a vermont farmer
named richard wiswall uh
he really sat down put pencil to paper
and figured it out for his vegetable
operation
and then he ended up writing a book
about it and included a cd in it with
with spreadsheets
and and cause and um budget sheets
um for for each crop that he grew uh
which is very very useful and i'm gonna
i'm gonna a lot of my examples come from
his work because i think it's still very
relevant today and it does pretty lines
up pretty well with what our costs are
in new york um so i'll get you more
information about that as i go along but
uh so between those two i've kind of
built this this whole presentation
around
so you you're looking at uh you know
figuring all your inputs everything
that's been purchased to grow your crop
and then you've got your practices so
whatever the activities needed to grow
those crops
you need to keep track of time how long
did it take to do those
tasks or activities
then you've got labor
either paying workers or yourself
to do those tasks need to keep track of
of that
um
and then
marketing you know selling requires time
and inputs and labor uh so those are the
time
inputs labor and time are the three
things that you're going to see here
over and over today
and then there's you know you've got
your your equipment costs and and
implements and and those types of you
know if you're growing transplants and
all of those factors
into that so when you add all these
together inputs plus crop practices plus
time plus labor marketing plus
activities
gives you your overall production costs
and that this was what feeds into the
the crop budgets
for each and every crop
uh
as an earlier slide it showed in there
about you know that
some some growers have lots and lots of
crops so maybe it's not
uh
you know maybe you just don't have
enough time to work it all out for 70 or
so crops but you can certainly put these
crops into into categories so a lot of
those crops may fall into category of
greens
um
and uh but i if you've got if you're
also doing um you know high tunnel
production as well as field crops you
may want to you know keep your tunnel
production as a separate
cost of production uh just because
there's some different some different
costs worked in there you want to keep
better track of that
high tunnels are pricey real estate and
you really need to get your your money
back from that investment
another crop group is your solanaceous
crops uh and just remember if you're
staking
uh you you've gotta you know put put in
the cause for steaks labor
uh for for staking and stringing and
then taking it all down putting it away
cleaning it to remove disease problems
um you know so those those are those are
some added costs you could you could
block together all your squash or your
brassicas or your root crops so you can
take a a lot of those you know
60 70 different crops and get it down to
five you know a basic basic five i mean
10 20 whatever it is that you want to
you know how specific do you want to get
with it
um
you could you could do it all as one
uh and just do it one large
you know everything's treated the same
you grow it growing it on the same
spacing it's taking up the same amount
of real estate um but it
it that's really in you end up with a
generalized number um
it may be good to you know if you if
that's the way you want to start off but
i i do you know
suggest that you really start becoming a
little bit more specific on some of
these things because there's there could
be some significant significant
differences
that will um that you want to keep track
of
especially if you've got a pricey
specialty crop mixed in that group or
like i said high tunnel stuff
um
and so uh using the the concepts that
richard wiswall put together he broke
everything down a lot of things down
also by
the the unit
his
his field grown units
he grew everything on
on
on the bed system
all of his beds were 350 feet long
had multiple rows
in there so 250 foot
two 350 foot beds
uh with double rows uh conveniently
works out to be about a tenth of an acre
so you're you're in that acre you know
so you've got a unit measure there you
know but so you can do it that way uh
you could do the square foot linear foot
bed length by width
in tunnels um
you might looking at doing the bed
method
for some crops may just fit better if
you're just doing open ground in rows or
by linear
feet
or if you've got really large plantings
you can go into that fraction or full
acre
unit
but you want to you want to figure out
things per unit so you can compare uh
that's that's the important thing you
want to break it down so that it it
makes sense on on a scale that's easily
comprehensible uh and then and when then
we when you want to scale back up
it's easy to do the computations
um so
per unit you know you're adding up all
of your inputs and associated practice
costs your labor
you know time
as i mentioned before
and
um then when you're adding in your your
marketing costs your overhead costs that
gives you your subtotal uh cost per crop
so that
that's part of that end result there
and then if you take those sub
total costs for crop times your total
unit of area times the number of crops
gives you your full total cost of
production over a season
uh and then if you subtract from that
all your uh you you take your total
sales of all those crops subtract out
your total costs that gives you uh your
end result not hopefully a big big
profit
so getting into the nuts and bolts
collecting that information it's it's
tiring it's tedious
uh
it's a it's a routine that you have to
get into but it's necessary
usually about now we get a question in
there is there an app for that
uh i i have looked at the question of
apps for a number of years
i i've talked to growers who say oh yeah
i just got this new app for you know
keep for record keeping and so i checked
back with them in a couple of seasons
and see and they're like well it really
didn't do what i wanted it to do
um
it uh it was a little bit more
cumbersome um so i ended up not using it
um so
it's i i don't have a
something in front of me that i can
really highly recommend uh i i can tell
you that one
one program that it's sort of basic and
i know some growers are using it it's
just google docs
working that
off of a smartphone or a tablet
seems to have done a really good job
for them uh they've got workers all
their workers have smartphones uh and
then so they they put them in charge of
certain crops in certain fields and they
they keep track of their records
post it in onto their uh
on onto the google docs and and then
they share it amongst the workers and
the the farmer so they have instant
information right there at their
fingertips so when it comes like to
filling orders or knowing you know how
you know
what what the what the yields are
uh for any given day uh during harvest
season they've got that information so
that that that's some of the some really
important things um
uh but i mean you can go as simple as
you know uh a clipboard with uh with
some sheets in there and and you know
write down your categories and just kind
of fill in columns and rows
those are some excel sheets uh that you
could use as well
that they all you know all fit in that
using excel
that's the one i'm a little bit more
used to but i guess there's google
sheets can do the same thing
um that they've got
uh formula functions that can help add
and add and subtract um
rows and columns and things so it does
does help you know once you get the hang
of it it's useful information can come
from there
um
so
let's jump in into into building
building this all together so starting
off with labor
you know we want to calculate out all
the hours workers are
uh
are down for and you know how much
you're paying them uh and don't forget
to include yourself yes pay yourself a
wage right away you know start with that
it's uh uh you're you're
it isn't what it's left over at the end
of the year
is your wage
that is that that is your profit
what you you need to include what you're
paying yourself into that calculation
that way you're guaranteed at least
you're making something so you could put
down your owner
uh in there and i'll show you an example
of a spreadsheet
uh in a minute um
so you you write down
you've got additional worker costs
perhaps our workman's comp payroll taxes
things like that can be put in there
if you've got workers receiving
different wages based on experience or
whatever uh you may want to keep track
of that specifically or you can estimate
it uh
run an average
on on the percent time spent per worker
or whatever
so you don't want to end up with what
how much you're really putting aside um
per hour for yourself and your workers
so
something like is like this you've got
your own you're paying yourself fifteen
dollars an hour you've got new workers
getting paid 15.
maybe you've got so many kinds been
coming back for a couple of years it's a
good worker you know maybe you've got
them going in 18 or more
um then you you've got employee taxes
workman's comp costs so you work that
out on a per hour basis
um
and then you end up with um you know you
labor costs for yourself and um you know
for an experienced person
so it's just you know 19 and 40 cents uh
per hour is what it's costing you for
that paying that experienced worker
uh if you're doing these um
these types of additions
all right move to to marketing so if
you're doing farmers markets you've got
the you know
the the labor of uh running inventories
loading trucks
traveling to the market setting up and
selling loading that truck back up
unloading taking an inventory putting
things back in the cooler is leftovers
for the next market day
uh you've got vehicle costs
uh you may have equipment uh that are
that lasts for several years so you
might want to amortize that cost over
two three four years whatever it might
be
you've got supply costs
per season so it could be sign small
signs produce bags boxes elastic bands
whatever
you may be paying market fees may have
market insurance they need to put all
that in there if you're uh accepting
credit cards or doing those types of um
ways of getting cash other than cash
those have associated costs as
well um
then you want to you know figure out the
costs uh going to market and this is
where you could divide it across uh the
number of crops that you bring um so
maybe you don't want to maybe you're not
bringing
maybe you're bringing just 20 crops
maybe you're bringing you know a you
know five
different crops you know different types
of crops whatever whatever that number
is that you decide on you know put that
in there in this example it's like
bringing 20 crops to the market so that
kind of roughly works out to be you know
five five percent of your your um
farmer's market costs can be attributed
uh
to each crop
so you have a spreadsheet that kind of
looks like this
um you've got
you've got your labor broken down
um
you know number of hours number of
workers you figure all that out in there
how your vehicle costs uh going to and
from round trip
uh your rental fees per day
at the market uh equipment and you're
going to want to do this like for each
market you go to uh or if it's the same
for
for for for each of them each market day
you know then just multiply that out um
but um you know total costs end up being
393
um
across that divided by the number of
crops you bring so the marketing costs
per crop it's about 19 you know almost
20 dollars
so if you're running a csa you know
you've got similar setup costs you've
got your labor uh you know and
you know pulling you know looking at
your inventory packing the containers uh
pickup site setups
you know reviewing which you know if you
have multiple types of memberships
signage newsletters communication time
spent at the pickup site uh maybe if
you've got multiple sites and you're
bringing stuff to
uh you've got to include vehicle costs
and all of that
to and from
wholesaling uh you know similar costs
you know a similar way of looking at it
with wholesaling as it is with retailing
um you can divide it out by the number
of crops
again uh but you know and you've got
you've got the labor of you know maybe
it's loading your trucks
driving it out to the buyer unloading it
or maybe they unload it whatever
you get your vehicle costs
uh you've got some amateurized costs in
there uh supply costs as well um
uh you've got more record keeping
perhaps so that that's an
added thing you have to consider um
it may be there's uh you're dealing with
a lot more quantity
so it takes more longer
to harvest and loading and things like
that you may have to grade and uh to a
specific
level or sizing to meet the the buyer's
needs um and then you may be doing more
wash pack
uh packaging labeling uh if you're
running you know if you guys following
food safety uh specifically if you're if
you're uh if you have like a gaps um
certification or something like that um
there's time spent with all of that kind
of thing uh a lot of wholesalers
requiring you know wholesale accounts
require that
um so uh moving on uh
one one thing that's often overlooked uh
when
you're looking at ag budgets are
overhead costs
this is often left out
it is all the associated costs that go
into having a business
but it isn't production and marketing
it's often made up of um you know if
you're if you buy a house with with five
acres it has a barn on it and you decide
you're gonna grow vegetables on there
you know so part of that property and
every uh and so the properties
associated costs
can be you know a percentage of that can
be put towards the business
into that so this often this is some of
the stuff that it includes
um
you know you're part of that mortgage
payment of of the of the living part of
the house uh there's part of that which
is business
um so you you can kind of estimate you
know how much of that might be 50 50
however you want to put it in there um
so you've got property taxes insurance
all of these so your overhead costs
could be fractions of this it could be
some speci you know it could be all of
all of the categories depending on what
it is
um
so um that is all important
considerations
uh and often uh overhead costs can be
really high
uh that's why i think some people like
that it's often overlooked because when
they look at how how high it is
uh they're like oh how do i figure that
into that this is crazy well you you
break it up all over um you know you
work it into the overall production um
you know and the overall crop sales that
you have and it actually breaks down
into into a smaller number from
whiswall's example like i said he does
every he did figured everything on on
350 foot beds
um and so he so his unit of measure was
two
350 foot beds so uh on on five acres
this actually works out you know if you
did if you farmed all of those five
acres it would be about a hundred beds
altogether uh so he he broke down his
overhead costs
uh from nineteen thousand to three
hundred and eighty three dollars uh
per two beds
so uh
let's get start getting into some
production so you've got your seating
and transplant production costs
uh there's a lot of items in there
um
that that for for consideration
um so you know right now everybody's out
training seating getting getting you
know their their plants going so you've
got soil you've got
cell trays inserts whatever it is that
you're using soil blocks
all of those you need to take into
consideration your costs what what you
have to purchase per season what can be
amateurized over a couple of seasons
so there you know you
somebody actually figured out that a
five-gallon bucket of scoop soil you
know bulk soil is an eighth of a cubic
foot um so
you can you can get it down to the to
the cell level practically on this uh
from one of wiswal's spreadsheets on
there he he did he did bedding plants as
well as vegetable transplants i stuck in
on the bottom there for 72 cell insert
uh with a 1020 tray
you know when you work it all out uh
each of you know for all of those costs
uh soil
labor
you know
all of those
all the things that go into it
each tray
uh filled is costing you a dollar 35. so
if you're doing you know if you're doing
300 trays you know that that that's
that's you know and that may not be a
huge amount of money if you're doing a
thousand trades it really starts adding
up so you know knowing that number can
be very important
if you're growing transplants don't
forget you know if you're putting them
in greenhouses or high tunnels there's
inputs that go along with that as well
getting into the meat
and potatoes here tractors and equipment
irrigation costs
you want to figure out your hourly cost
of operating
that large ticket items uh with long
useful lives you can spread out those
costs over a bunch of years
so you divide those costs over the given
years
and
to reflect depreciation as well
then you want to look at number of hours
or you know estimate number of hours
used per season
uh you know and you think about it all
of the different activities you might
use a tractor for or a wagon or whatever
uh you know it can add up
you've got fuel costs you know and the
prices of that has really skyrocketed
lately
uh and then you've got the the labor for
time to operate that
uh and the irrigation you know similar
type of thing you know
it costs you money to set things up
especially if you're doing like overhead
and you've got to run around moving a
lot of pipe around you know 10 or 15 20
times during the season uh or more um
that that's
gonna account for that
here's another spreadsheet example on
that um
some of the some of these uh
original price useful life
of of different types of
tractors
so he's figuring 25 years uh you know
whatever you think you can get out of a
out of a piece of equipment use that
number um so that work works it out per
year
uh and then it breaks it down to you
know tractor with driver
per hour 25 and 70 cents uh to operate
that
just the tractor alone
uh and then work this out for your for
your implements as well so you've got
you know whatever whatever the costs are
there number of years
um
maybe it was a little bit optimistic at
20 years for a brush hog i don't know
um maybe i'm a little low for a manure
spreader
but uh those you know
it it works out you know a small amount
of money per hour but it's still there
time this is one thing that growers seem
to have uh you know really have trouble
trying to track down how long it takes
to come for for activities to be
completed you don't need to stop watch
on
you know to time everybody but you know
if you if you if you get you know you
could you could delegate some of this
information gathering to workers you
know if you've got teams out there doing
they can keep track of you know what
time do they start and then what time do
they finish
and um you know things like that so it
but it's really important to get an idea
just how long does it take to complete
all the activities
on the farm
you know where does your money go when
you're paying somebody this is where you
want to break it down to
so list out all the activities estimate
the time it takes to get a task done you
can do that now
and then kind of keep track over the
course of a season
and uh then at the end of the year um go
back and and use the numbers that you
figured uh and and and compare it to the
estimates that you might put together
now and you know and adjust accordingly
so um you want to
you know keep track during that season
uh re-figure those calculations as
needed uh and this exercise gives you
really clear indication of what's taking
the most time you know um and maybe even
you know some people you might know some
people are getting job done jobs done
faster than others
could be important uh as we go along uh
to talk about that
uh so uh where where can you uh you know
improve efficiency what it might take
and weeding's always there on the top of
the list if you have to go you know if
you're chilling with a tractor but you
still have to go back and bring in the
crew to do hand weeding
you know
maybe if the tillage uh
or the cultivation uh was improved
somehow maybe another piece of equipment
uh you could cut out uh the the labor of
having people to hand weed or hoeing
maybe he's moving from overhead
irrigation to a different type
of you know maybe maybe it's drip or
whatever
on steak tomatoes may take a lot longer
to harvest uh than steak ones
yeah uh maybe it's uh you're having
problems in the wash pack off uh shed uh
things aren't taking you too long to set
it up
for for each day's use whatever it is
you can this is where you can figure it
out
so uh let's let's let's start all right
let's so we're we're the season's under
the way we've got the the you know
everything ready to go uh soil prep
you've got a uh you know
these are examples of the types of
activities that go out and go on
during that time of the year
um you know for each of those
you want you know it you know what how
much time did it take uh and and labor
units
involved uh what's your equipment costs
you know was there any inputs purchased
so maybe you you're spreading some
fertilizer or adding some herbicide or
whatever those types of things get
worked into here
um
uh so and you want to you want to
collect data so for the next few slides
everything you want to collect the data
on all these things
uh so you know and you know and keep
track how many times did did you have to
use um you know do these uh types of
activities with with that equipment
uh seating and transplanting you know if
you direct seeding or if you're if
you're gonna go transplant out there you
know so you've got associated activities
uh and then for each of those again time
labor equipment input
inputs
uh fieldwork
so if you're using you know putting out
row cover if you're hand weeding or
hoeing
adding mulch whatever whatever these you
know you know
this list
might be longer for you might be shorter
you know depending on your how you do
things but you want to keep track of all
that information
then you want to you know get ready for
harvest and then actually do the harvest
um you know just
you know that that that takes time
but uh and so there's there's there's
quite a quite a list here could be
bigger as i said
and then at the end of the year
uh finally finished all done well you
still have to you know put everything
away clean up afterwards so that that's
time that you need to to
add as well you know if you're putting
in a cover crop you know the cost of
seed
uh whatever uh adding uh maybe spreading
manure
this is um this is the time to
you know add that to the accounts
so now we've gone through all of those
categories and it's time to
kind of put it all together so you're
adding up all of these all these pieces
free plant plus direct seeding and
transplanting plus field work plus free
harvest plus harvest post harvest
plus your overhead costs and your
marketing costs equals your total costs
per crop
so then you take that cost of your crop
and then you
mark it up to give you your selling
price
uh so it's it's over this is the amount
it's over and above what your costs are
and that that's going to give you your
profit at the end of the day so don't be
afraid to market up high you know you're
growing the best quality produce there
is you know you're proud of what you
grow you know and you want to get your
price for it don't feel like you have to
you know
of of uh that it has to be lower there's
this great myth out there
uh that's ruining farming i think is is
this myth is that food has to be cheap
uh it could you know it costs to to grow
it and you need to be paid for it i mean
you know the the car car manufacturers
and car dealers aren't ashamed to jack
their prices up
uh i think it's time farmers do the same
thing as well
um
so but you need to adjust your prices
based on the data
and that's what this this exercise is
all about you're collecting this
information so that you can make
informed decisions
so
this is this is these the next few
slides are taken from
a crop budget based on all of the costs
that were were added up as we went
through
so this is uh again this is for bush
beans that were grown on two double row
beds 350 foot long again that's a tenth
of an acre
this is from wiswalt's budgets crop
budgets
uh so he's got you know
for for the the soil prep and these top
items you know the consideration is for
his labor was 106. equipment 22 supply
costs 50.
then and
get the harvest they harvested 500
pounds took 42 hours
um and then
field the the pack house and and the
associated costs above
uh
plus you know packing getting everything
ready to go into the cooler
uh and uh and then you know bagging for
the packaging uh those those numbers are
all there
so it's post saw post harvest look at
labor equipment and supplies
um it was mowing disking cover crop
seeding
so adding up from the previous page
to this one so now we're up to 660
dollars in labor equipment supplies are
all are all increasing
you're adding in your marketing costs
to that you know for those beans
uh so your total crop costs are you know
for labor is 700 over 730 dollars
equipment
still 29 88
for supplies
then you get 853
you add your overhead costs as from the
previous example so you get a grand
total of 1141 dollars
to to grow
500 pounds of beans
so if you're setting a price without
knowing this kind of information
you know let's just say uh that you're
going to the farmer's market you've got
your beans are in one pound units
and you're selling them at two dollars
each because the person next to you at
the farmer's market always sells theirs
for two dollars
so you're you're matched there so if you
sold all 500 pounds it's a thousand
dollars in sales
so if you minus sales minus all your
costs so a thousand minus 1141
means you've lost
almost 142
dollars not a good thing
selling price
setting prices knowing the data so if
you've got 500 pounds that you're
selling
you want to you want to come up with
unit cost so you divide the total costs
by the the harvest amount
gives you two dollars and 28 cents a
pound so that's the minimum
you have to sell it for just to break
even
just to break even it's going to be two
dollars and 28 cents a pound
so
let's just say then i'm gonna that
you're gonna sell it for two dollars and
fifty cents a pound because you've got
three people that's
surrounding you that's selling theirs
for two dollars a pound but you're going
to sell yours for 250 a pound and you're
going to have a big you're going to have
a really nice sign and you're going to
have a nice display that really shows
off these really gorgeous beans
so you're
you're you're if you set it at 250
times 500 you get 12 1250
minus your your costs of 1141
gives you a small profit
of 108
but it's a profit and remember you've
paid yourself already
on this this covers all of your costs
and you made this profit
so profit equals your income from sales
minus your total expenses as i've
already mentioned
um
so
knowing if you made a profit or not
procrasti gives you some really valuable
information and helps you out you know
the answers to those big questions we
covered in the in the beginning
so you it so since that was a loss on
those beans i don't i don't want to
leave that so there was a loss there so
let's you use that data collected on the
costs to figure out where changes might
be able to be made
you know if it's a loss how much why you
know where you know so so
it appears like too much labor may have
been spent weeding or inefficient labor
uh during harvesting uh and remember
from that example it's 42 hours to
harvest 500 pounds of beans
maybe there's a better way of doing that
you know finding a better way to to weed
maybe is a better way of harvesting
maybe you've got slow pickers maybe you
need you know find somebody that can
pick beans faster maybe growing pole
beans instead of bush beans maybe that's
faster
maybe
if you if you think you can sell a lot
of beans maybe
buying a mechanical
bean picker might be uh a way around
that i mean if you can find one used
that that might become you know you
might be able to sell more beans pay for
the mechanical harvester by not paying a
bunch of people you know spend 42 hours
picking beans i have one grower that did
that a number of years ago he had uh it
was five five people picking beans uh
taking like a total of 16 or 20 hours
total
man hours to pick beans you got a
mechanical bean picker he did the same
he could pick what five people did in
that amount of time in about 20 minutes
uh that bean picker pick you know paid
for itself
it was used uh brand new ones are really
unbelievably expensive but used ones are
available
um
or maybe the answer is you don't grow
beans at all especially if you've got
everybody else is selling beans and if
they're certainly probably not making
any more money than you are at two
dollars a pound you're probably losing
money so maybe you don't want to grow
beans maybe you can do better on
something else
there's also a thing i'll touch on about
benchmarking labor costs um that there's
there's some interest in that uh it's
figuring out how much time certain tasks
really should be taking and you measure
your labor against that
to see where you fall in line i'll talk
about that in a minute
um
so uh you know having inventory sheets
is really important i think uh it's a
good piece of information lists what
props are available uh that you're
bringing to market gives you all sorts
you know you can add all sorts of
information into that uh so that um you
can you can easily come up with uh you
know with
how much is sold at the end of the day
um you know by by knowing how much you
brought minus how much is left at the
end of the day tells you gives you how
much that you've sold uh you can keep
track of different markets um and and
these types of things really important
information
um
so uh you know it also gives you you
know um
amount of each crop that that was
brought to market is good harvest record
information if you don't do that already
here's a a an easy sheet to put together
for that kind of thing
so uh just just want to kind of wrap up
here um so richard wiswalt his book is
the organic farmer's handbook
uh you can find that online chelsea
green
uh publishers puts it out uh i think you
can get it through amazon as well
he has a lot of crop budgets there from
you know all quite quite quite the
number in there plus he's got some
empty crop templates and and blank ones
that you can build your own if you're so
inclined um
but yeah and you don't have to be
organic to use this information plus the
book has a lot of other things really
useful business information that's in
there so it's got it makes an
interesting read but like i said it has
a cd-rom that has excel spreadsheets
that are that you can use i've got a
couple of examples of you know as i've
showed already
um so but you can play around with
changing the numbers
in these scenarios in there and if you
know the only the only fault i have with
it is that the the uh
the sheets that are that are used for
for when you're filling them out for you
know figure out your labor cost the
market costs and and all those costs
they're not linked to the crop budgets
but if you know if you have somebody
that you know who's good with excel
spreadsheets they can they can create
links so that when you put the
information in on those
on your on your sheets like equipment
costs and those types of things it'll
automatically changes the the the crop
budget sheets
uh and it makes makes it really a much
more useful tool and you can change
around the selling price to see you know
how much money you would be making
there's a lot there that you can use
this for
uh so here here's just like that um
[Music]
bean
sheet so it's it's a very long uh
um
spreadsheet on there so i just put
pieces of that in there to show you is
you're working through each of the
section you can you know from the
cultivation to the harvest
um post harvest your marketing costs
and then you work it down to your sales
so he's got both works in their
wholesale and retail
opportunities you can change around
these price setting the price setting
the yields uh the amount of time that it
costs know that it takes to do things
you you can change these all around
then it gives you your net profits
you know and then you can play around
with numbers to see all right what you
know how when do i make a real profit
not a loss um and and and come up with
that so really important stuff
there's another set of sheets out there
um
that it's all unfortunately they're not
they're not excel spreadsheets they're
just sheets of information new england
vegetable crop budgets was put together
by
umass and university new hampshire back
around 2000
it doesn't have it doesn't have a lot of
different crops has the major ones
there's a
the link to them uh and they don't have
quite all of the same costs uh in there
either like they don't um have um
overhead costs in there and and some of
your read um you know selling costs
but um
you know this here's an example on
peppers
um so so this this sheet goes over
um
you know all the kind of like
the activities that go on in the field
for growing peppers on an acre
um
here's all the labor costs they break it
out between uh experienced labor or you
know labor that that you're that you're
retaining
and new labor uh so there's two
different two different uh pay rates
there
um then you've got cash expenses per
acre uh for um you know your chemical
inputs and and all those types of things
it's all worked out um you've got all
the equipment costs in there so there's
more types of equipment here than on on
what whiz walls
has
listed um and then it's it's the summary
of of the but the budget so you know
total production costs for an acre of
peppers you know forty eight hundred
sixty six dollars
so then he does uh these grow gross
revenue chart so based on yield of uh
you know uh one in the ninth bushel box
uh it is sold at different uh various
prices this is on various yields this is
how much of the sales and then if you
subtract out the uh the costs to that so
you can see that there's losses uh you
know it's six and eight dollars uh
per box at if it's if your yields are
750
boxes per acre
and then and it works its way up so it's
it's got some good information uh
interesting stuff there so i i i'd
say you know if you put both of these
together
uh it could be a great resource for you
so
knowing your costs help answer these big
questions
efficiency helps a lot but you know you
got to know where and how and what's
impacted
uh if you're going to take on debt
you've got to be cautiously
uh move cautiously and base it on real
numbers
and to figuring out how to be paid be
conservative don't be overly optimistic
be conservative you know we're we're
having a situation now you know where
we're seeing you know and our next
presentation here we're talking about
protecting your investment
uh you know with these extreme weather
events we're we're seeing more and more
total losses
uh than than i think one than what we
have had in in the past so i think it's
it's a it's a good thing now to really
be thinking about that
um and then benchmarking as mentioned
before uh
this got out of iowa state university
they've got uh they started looking at
at benchmarking um and i just found this
so i haven't really had a chance to go
through it uh but it's looking at some
various crops and uh the time it takes
for labor to complete the tasks
so
there we go um and then like i said um
got fsa coming up joanne in a minute
uh so
stay tuned for that please
uh so uh i can take a few questions
before we start
robert i'll ask you a question this is
steve um
why why do you think it is that
universities across the country they
they used to provide all this budget
information and now we
cornell stopped doing it years ago
i guess they were ahead of their time
but you just can't find it anymore is it
just because of the time it takes or
what
i think i think so uh and it's funny
when i i started looking at this
actually about eight or ten years ago uh
was looking at cost of production
uh and then i sort of did a literature
review of what was available so let's
see so that was like 2012 so between
2010 2012 i started digging through
stuff so yeah you're right there were a
lot of universities that provided this
information and if you went looking at
their at what they had there and then go
look at their references a lot of them
would would refer back to some previous
work and then you go to those and a lot
of them go back to previous work even
even further back and and a lot of them
ended up at the same place
that i i found it was university of
kentucky back in like the 1970s uh
growing cabbage
and um
and and that was uh and so they they you
know uh it was based on on a state that
was you know
and a time frame when things were a
whole lot cheaper uh and and labor was
ridiculously low price
uh and and so i think a lot of it became
it was just out of just out of step with
what with reality
uh and then a lot of ag business
programs just i i don't know they just
didn't have the resources or the time to
really dig into it um
so you're right there is not a lot of
really current fresh information out
there
um you know for for our area that you
know that that's really relevant so
these are the two sources the umass and
the richard willis walls are the two you
know that i go to
uh because they seem to you know at
least be more reflective
of what's really going on yeah well
thank you
robert we do have a question in the chat
from michael do you have any advice for
growers deal customer pushback on price
increases at farmers markets
uh
yeah that's a that's a really great
question and and it's and it really has
you know i i've seen i've seen customers
will will argue over
uh you know like a
a bunch of radishes like like 18
radishes and a bunch because i counted
the bunch
uh on this when i saw this happen it was
it was uh the farmer was selling it for
75 cents for 18 radishes and the
customer didn't want to pay more than
50.
uh when you when you and then walked
away because it wouldn't lower the price
i i think
i i really i'm convinced you know
if you've got a customer like that
you're never going to make them happy
you know they they have this impression
that farmers don't you know i don't know
don't deserve money or something i don't
know they're doing it for the love of it
i i don't i don't know i've heard this
rather recently over the winter uh
that oh
um
farmers who are you know trying to push
up their prices uh and customers were
saying well you know i i want why are
you charging more than a supermarket
well you're comparing apples to oranges
you're you know you've got vine ripe
fresh high quality product it's grown
right here uh you know with a with a
farmer you can go back to week after
week
or
buying buying this this this great
product uh and it is much better than
what you're gonna find in the
supermarket for the most part you know
and and going into you know where did
that product come from who grew it how
far did it travel did it even come from
this country uh and and
and
and those types of things
i think you tie that in with having some
really nice merchandising i mean putting
uh putting together a really nice
display
lots of signage uh and and and talk
about you know how good the crop is how
you know you know what it takes to grow
it don't be afraid to tell them you know
you know it this it's
it's it's not you know
this is you know cheap food is a myth
and it really it has a cost
associated with it and you're i'm giving
you a better product than you'll ever
find in the supermarket
well that that's you know that
that's my advice
and i i go uh my wife's a cut flower
grower i go to the farmer's market with
her uh and um and
it's you know and and you have to sell
it i mean you know you've got it it
doesn't sell itself anymore you've
really got it you know and i've watched
the growers all around me the ones who
just stand there and don't say anything
and just sit there like customers pick
you know pick things out or not
versus other ones who start up a
conversation uh and and talk about their
produce
um so uh and and explain why it costs
more
um i i've got a couple of growers uh are
adamant they sell uh they sell
a small box of cherry tomatoes five
dollars
you know that that's their price and and
then they say you know you know here
taste one
tell you know this is the best tomato
you're gonna ever eat um and he sells
out so
you know be proud of what you got push
it
all right
so basically the farm service agency
i'll just do a brief overview um you
know what we're here for is to help any
type uh farmer any size any type grower
of commodities to implement um there's
generally
county offices in most counties
sometimes you're a shared county but
we're here to kind of help uh manage and
support our local farmers
i'll kind of just skip through these
slides real quick and then i'm going to
get into some of the fact sheets that i
think are going to be a little bit more
helpful um in regard to what the next
step is possibly if you are interested
um with participating with the farm
service agency
or
as a sister usda agency
and basically we are here to try to help
protect
the american farmers i'm going to go
over some programs that are disaster
weather related that can possibly assist
some
local growers
and this is kind of an overview of new
york state so there is um and one change
here karen rugenstein in our local
ontario county has retired but we do
still have a farm loan team uh working
diligently so if lending or finances are
needed
but this kind of gives an overview of
all of our counties for new york state
we have farm lung programs and farm
programs so if you need
lending opportunities this is a nice uh
looks like a sugar shack and we do have
storage um loans that we do have for low
interest
or hoop houses a different type of
lending opportunities
and beginning farmers and i kind of put
this in here if anybody is a beginning
farmer beginning farmer meaning probably
reporting on your taxes you may have
grown up on a farm your whole life or
been involved in farms but when it's
actually your farm and you're reporting
it for taxes purposes
and under 10 years you are considered a
beginning farmer and when i go over the
nap program that gives give you some
cost savings where you can have some
entry-level coverage no additional fees
so um beginning farmer you can certify
to that there's a a form for that and
then
this a presentation was put in the box
the link should hopefully work and you
would be able to find
um further information about beginning
farmers there's a lot of information on
our website
and then getting into risk coverage and
also grant opportunities um usda does
have a lot of grant opportunities a lot
of people ask about them currently it
appears american marketing services are
doing a lot of our grant
opportunities
another is they could be usda funded but
you may want to check with new york
state ag and markets they may also have
something and then here's a big one that
we're talking about risk is for the risk
management agency
rma or crop insurance and that link can
take you to some protection and i do
have a specially cropped fact sheet
that i've supplied that can kind of give
you an overview of whether related
losses or income losses in regard to
your farm operation
and that you do go through there's a
locator that you can find it right
through crop insurance agents that
actually sell
to local producers for crop coverage
and this is the nap um and there's a
fact sheet so i just did kind of a
highlight of it this is for the
protection for you for weather related
losses it's called their non-insured
crop
assistance program this is when
financial uh crop insurance is not
available through risk management
through cropping the regular crop
insurance so maybe they don't cover
tomatoes or peppers or garlic or
flowers the non-insured assistance
program assistant program often referred
to as nap can help you with that and if
you're a beginning farmer or a female
farmer socially disadvantaged or a
veteran farmer um that's also a
beginning farmer
the
entry level fee is waived for that so
you would have
um the
50 loss level with 55 of the price not
to get too far in it i think you would
want to reach out to the farm service
agency and have them go over details and
the fact she does do a good job of
covering that
so if one of those categories you may
want to look it into it it's
no matter what size farm you are
the one thing i do want to um and robert
touched upon this often is the record
keeping
so the not insured the net program does
need record keeping because it is off of
your producer yield so our benefit is
developed by
the yield that you have on your farm
these are some deadlines so march 15th
which is just uh
less than a week away is next tuesday
make sure you reach out to the farm
service agency most of our spring
uh seated crops are coming up for next
tuesday if you do want the nap uh
coverage for that so make sure you
contact that fsa office and robert had
the locator
link there
in his presentation that you can find
and get that coverage if that's
something that suits you that protects
you with weather related losses
it is a little bit of work up at the
beginning because we developed a
three-year history to be able to get
your yield established for that
but it is good protection other weather
related losses and you do have to have
this uh
coverage in place prior
to the weather event because sometimes
fsa does have disaster programs but this
is an insurance it's like other
insurance you need to have it in place
prior to the loss
the other thing that comes in uh with
that and regardless of whether you do
the nap program um
or crop insurance or that we recommend
that you prop report with us there's no
cost for crop reporting unless it's late
filed um past our crop reporting
deadline
here's a highlight of what our deadlines
july 15th is kind of a big one for most
of our spring seeded crops your tomatoes
your peppers um
and
you know most of the veggie type crops
so
keep that in mind oftentimes the crop
reporting is our foundation that builds
off of most of our programs we did have
some pandemic assistance and that way we
know that that producer exists and we
can try to reach out to you to keep you
informed of any um programs that also
could help above and beyond maybe the
nap
program so that's uh crop reporting keep
that in mind
and then to work with the usda here is
also another link for finding the local
office uh we're fortunate new york state
things have been improving we are open
by appointment now so please always call
ahead and fsa office can make an
appointment for you
and get you a farm and track
we do have rooftop now we have
hoop houses
there's not an acres requirement or size
uh but generally speaking it's for
commercial farm operations you know your
your home garden wouldn't include but um
anybody you know going to farmers
markets those type are selling a stand
at your
farm
you may want to get set up with us
at the farm service agency
and generally what you need is just uh
we'll would need your name and address
and if you are going to be earning
program benefits with us of uh
participating like nap and actually
purchasing the coverage we would need to
know if you're an individual your social
security number because payments are
tracked through that or if you're an
entity it would be your
ein number
and then proof of ownership or leases um
we can work through that we in ontario
county monroe they we do have a means to
kind of find out ownership but and um we
can also that um you know if it's rented
ground that you're we have the right
operator on that
so registering your farm with um the
farm service agencies there are no fees
associated with that of getting a farm
in the track uh just call ahead and we
want to make sure that we're inclusive
it's all kinds all sorts of farmers that
we'd like to reach out to um any size
um it's in background so
please reach out to the farm service
agency
and then here are some website
information there's a ton of information
out there so it can be overwhelming so
it may be beneficial to contact the farm
service agency and they can
go over
you know our programs with you and help
you navigate through that
and i'll hold it is there any questions
currently for me of anything that
anybody like answered
and then here's some context i just did
some surrounding ones so in case in
regard to that um
that
would be available for contact in monroe
county wayne county ontario county but
obviously you can find that you can call
eve any one of these offices and we can
get you any other office that may be
needed for that
i think what would be also very
beneficial is to go over some of the
fact sheets that um steve and robert has
um
placed in the uh
so i'll share those
and this is a kind of a night can
everybody see that let me see here
joran we do have a question in the chat
would you like to take it now yeah sure
that'd be great
um so we have a question from matthew
could you talk a little bit more on the
hoop house grants
for the hoop house it's not necessarily
a grant but that's our sister agency
natural resource and conservation
service they do have hoop houses
projects that they do um through
some conservation programs that they
have for the hoop houses
so you could contact um fsa and we can
certainly refer you over for natural
resource and conservation services i
know ontario county has had a great
success with some hoop houses for some
local growers i think neighboring
other neighboring towns have had
opportunities as well to assist with um
getting hoop houses established and
that's through our sister agency and our
cs
awesome we do have another question as
well
right
need to be a specific amount of time to
acquire an fsa id number
there's not a amount of time it's not
like the irs for your submit for a tax
id you come in and you self-certify um
how you're like farming so if you're an
individual we would be just getting your
name and address and your social
security number
if you're a joint venture and you have a
tax id we would be getting that
some of our local growers have gotten
you know into an llc and incorporated so
we just want to match however you are
actually farming we match that up to our
farm records
so if you've applied for an ein number
that ss4 form you get back would be
helpful because it has exactly how your
name appears and how your id
number is established because that does
connect
um through you know the government
agencies
all right all set okay and this is the
new farmers this is like getting started
this is one of our newer factions it's
actually very helpful this is the new
farmers um they were kind enough to put
it in the cornell box of doing it for
the new farmers of getting started it
kind of gives you a 101. you know it has
the farm service agency it talks about
our natural resource and conservation
services it has that risk management
agency that's where the crop insurance
part of it comes in
rule developments listed here
if there's any producers that have a
value added so possibly you have berries
that you're picking that you're going to
be going in and doing jams into they
have a value-added program it's a grant
program that you submit an applica
an application for
that's another sister usda agency to not
overlook that there might be
available to you for funding
opportunities for that
and then of course we are for our
cooperative extension is a very great
value a valuable resource
that helps us with
you know
yield information or crop development a
variety of
information to help
assist with our program administration
and then here's getting started make an
appointment and then we would vet with
you what to bring um you know bring your
id information how you operate your farm
we'd want to know where your farm is so
if you do decide to crop report it that
we have that available
if that isn't already in the system we
get you a farm and track assigned to
that
and
then we kind of go over maybe what type
of programs you might be interested in
maybe the nat program
we have a farm stored facility loan
program that gets uh that helps with
funding say that you need a truck to go
to farmers market
that's available
cold storage they've really um expanded
upon that so we'd kind of talk to you
about that on number three
and this kind of gives you a 101 we'll
get you a pharm number and the tracks
we would um you know kind of make sure
we know about the food security act and
what the eligibility is to participate
with our programs um that leads us into
the like the 80 10 26 there is
compliance um that we have
for our programs
and then some eligibility if you were
interested in participating
um a producer has to certify that their
income after expenses is less than or
more than 900 000
and then go over your program
application maybe crop reporting um get
you connected to us if you want emails
for our bullet delivery bulletins or to
receive text messages
and then we would kind of go over your
acreage reporting and then you know
keeping in touch with us and our gov
delivery is making sure that we try to
um
reach out to you to let you know of any
programs coming up
and then um can you still see this now
okay
for the crop acreage report yes okay and
that's that's really the foundation of
kind of getting started after you get
your farm and track as we encourage prop
reporting because if there is a pandemic
program that comes up then we would know
uh we had an opportunity for people that
had gross sales
that were hurt during the pandemic
to be invited to participate if they
were interested in that
as well as crop reporting is going to be
required for the nap program i think
this also
pairs with what robert was saying about
the record keeping
we are going to have to have your your
rows in your spacing
because that does matter so if your rows
are 12 feet apart versus six feet or ten
that's going to make a big difference on
your yield information um you know so we
can kind of go over some of our standard
spacing and to be able to get the
appropriate acreage because we would
want to have that reflected properly to
help with your yield information so i
think robert gave a lot of good
information and overview about how you
report and how to measure for your crops
that information would be asked so that
we could capture your crop reporting
acres accurately
and then here's just kind of an overview
again like getting beginning farmer you
know contacting us for an appointment
for most of our spring seeded scrap
crops again it is going to be july 15th
we do have a big peak of prop reporting
so i would contact the fsa office sooner
than later to make sure you get on the
radar if you are interested in getting
your crops reported
this sheet here is just an overview of
disaster assistance i kind of left it in
because it does show variety of the farm
service agencies listed here for the the
nap program
um if you have fruit trees and they're
lost to an ice storm or something
there's a tap program or if it's
grapevines that are lost
that we do our christmas trees that
program may be of interest disaster
related wise to help uh eliminate some
of the
expenses the tap program helps you to
replant if you lose
christmas trees during a weather event
or grapevines
the non-insured assistance program is
that revenue production that robert
spoke about and if you are a beginning
farmer or an sba or a veteran beginning
farmer that fee is way for the entry
level the 325 per crop up to 8.25 is
weighed
so that may have been an interest to you
because then it would be you know kind
of cat catastrophe type coverage for you
and then here gives it all the crop
insurance that's through risk management
agency
uh you would contact a local agent um
you could go to the rma website and
they'll give you an agent locator
i really highly recommend kind of
talking around and seeing if you do
decide that because they do have some
specialty crop
coverage that they've just come out with
is try to talk around this if um to
other producers if they are using crop
insurance what agent they use you you
would want an agent that's familiar with
props
maybe more so than just your vehicle
coverage or your barn coverage um that
they're knowledgeable about crops and
what what they're covering um for that
um
so that's kind of in a nutshell an
overview and again here's nrcs if you
have lost to physical losses erosion or
different environmental
problems that are on your farm they may
be able to assist with some of the
conservation planning for you on on your
farm
and then here not to get too far into
the
the weeds on things of if you make an
appointment we would a farm service
agency would go over that nap program
with you
um crops that aren't covered under
conventional crop insurance so it can be
a little bit tricky
cabbage in ontario county you can get
that right through conventional crop
insurance so we wouldn't have the nap
coverage for you
um
but if you're in another neighboring
county that cabbage is not insurable
then we would offer you the nap program
so there's uh some specifics by even
counties
um the coverage level that entry level
coverage is the kind of the one that i
mentioned the 325 up to 825 if you're
just in one county that covers done all
your crops
if you're a multi-county there is a
maximum of that as well
and then as i stated there is beginning
farmer limited resource and other means
to be able to help you to waive those
fees if you qualify
and then if you decide to do the buy-up
that you want to protect yourself more
than just the
entry-level coverage of you know 50
percent loss and 55
of the price
you can actually go up to 65
production loss so a 35 loss and 100 of
the price
and it goes it's a calculation by your
number of acres to try to have it be
more suited to covering what do you have
out there is um of coverage
opportunities of um of your wrist and
then
multiply and we have a tool that we
could run for you to give you a little
bit of an idea
and if you are one of those um
beginning farmers or
socially disadvantaged you get 50 off of
the buy-up
coverage and and i do want to a kind of
uh relay on what robert was talking
about is the record keeping it it
doesn't have to be fancy but you do have
to have record keeping so even if you
have a tally a picktally
um sheet uh you know
each day of what you're doing um because
a lot of times you aren't writing out
receipts it's not going to be like a
wholesale operation but we do have a
means of still assisting those smaller
operations but you you do have to keep
track of your
um crop production
so that's kind of goes over um if you're
interested uh you know contact the fsa
office and we can go into specifics for
you on that
and then this is the one that is for the
specialty crop this is through risk
management that's where you would
actually go to a crop insurance agency
and they would go over um like a whole
farm revenue maybe you're not as good of
a
a record-keeping well maybe then this
would be a better suited fit for you
where it goes over comparison of revenue
if you don't have
that other record keeping this is a
whole farm revenue production
insurance program
and for the details on that um we don't
currently you know we don't administer
it so you would want to go through your
agent to have them um go through that or
look through the fact sheet and there is
a link for
going over to specifics on that
and here's that locator tool
i mentioned on the second page it'll go
where where can you buy those
this written agreement so say maybe
yates county doesn't cover cabbage well
they can maybe do a written agreement
saying yes the neighboring county does
so you can actually get it through crop
insurance if that's a better fit for it
um so the for the risk protection a
couple different
resources farm service agency as well as
our
crop insurance through risk management
is there any other
questions
so i i appreciate the opportunity to be
invited and hopefully that's helpful of
resources for uh local
producers
thank you so much joanne and thank you
to robert
wow those were really interesting talks
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu